bonjour françois lafforgue merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france comment est ce que vous avez
accueilli cette décision judiciaire avec
soulagement c'est vrai que c'est fait
des pilotes d'un long combat judiciaire
et aujourd'hui on peut se féliciter de
cette décision qui reconnaît
définitivement la responsabilité de
monsanto
cette victoire à ce qu'elle peut en
amener d'autres fin juin bayer a aussi
indemniser cent mille victimes
américaines du du roundup hauteur de 9
milliards d'euros un procès américain
qui peut redonner de l'espoir la france
a disons que aujourd'hui la décision
rendue par la plus haute juridiction
française ouvre une brèche pour des
victimes de pesticides qui peuvent
envisager des actions en responsabilité
contre les fabricants de pesticides
lorsqu'ils ont été intoxiqués par ces
produits en quoi cette bataille
judiciaire peut-elle changer les choses
au niveau des réglementations des
pesticides il parallèlement à ce type de
procédure nous engagions des procédures
pour faire retirer du marché des
pesticides dangereux notamment ceux qui
sont atteints tôt aux abeilles donc il
ya des procédures a parallèlement pour
contre ces pesticides et s'est mise en
vente de pesticides
concernant les victimes des petits no id
exactement ou de dérivés des
néonicotinoïdes et parallèlement à ça on
intervient pour des victimes de
pesticides pour qu'elles soient reconnus
en maladie professionnelle lorsqu elles
sont salariées agricoles ou exploitants
agricoles et le cas échéant qu'elles
recherchent la responsabilité des
fabricants parce que aujourd'hui la
décision de la cour de cassation de
cette possibilité-là aux victimes de
rechercher la responsabilité des
fabricants mais avec des décisions comme
comme celle d'hier est ce que ça peut
amener les gouvernements à agir
davantage vous venez d'évoquer les
néonicotinoïdes on sait que l'assemblée
a voté un pour la réintroduction de ces
pesticides notamment pour pour la
betterave
oui effectivement mais nous nous battons
aussi sur ce terrain là puisque nous
engageons des recours nous venons
d'obtenir une décision importante de
l'accord justice de l'union européenne
précisément sur sur cette question des
néonicotinoïdes donc nous
nous allons poursuivre le combat
judiciaire parce que nous avons des
possibilités d'actions y compris contre
les réglementations qui serait
permissive pour revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé hier la justice doit dorénavant
statuer sur les dommages et intérêts
réclamés par paul françois quelle
indemnisation pourront être obtenus
selon vous mais nous nous demandons à
près d'un million d'euros
ces demandes ne sont pas exorbitants de
l'entente du comparé à ce qui peut être
obtenue aux thèses unis mais ça nous
paraît envisageable en france de
demander ce petit de montant pour les
préjudices qui sont extrêmement
importants la fille de paul françois a
été définitivement obéré la suite à
l'intoxication à ce pesticide
d'autres procédures judiciaires sont en
cours contre l'utilisation des
pesticides on l'a dit est ce que cette
affaire elle peut servir d'exemple pour
l'avenir pour d'autres victimes en voit
ce que ça peut faire jurisprudence
oui je crois qu'on peut parler d'une
jurisprudence paul-françois contre
monsanto dans la mesure où la cour de
cassation dans un arrêt qui de 43 pages
n'est de 17 pages de motivation
extrêmement détaillé rejetant point par
point les arguments développés par
monsanto ne donne une grille de lecture
sur les actions qui peuvent être
engagées par d'autres victimes de
pesticides donc on peut parler
effectivement compte tenu de la nature
de la décision rendue par la plus haute
juridiction française d'une
jurisprudence
merci françois lafargue d'avoir répondu
à la question je rappelle que vous êtes
l avocat de paul françois dans la sphère
qui il oppose d'empierrement son temps